it's been six long weeks stuck inside
for six-year-old Marco and his parents
in their apartment in central Madrid and
it's been hard for all of them kid over
his 18 it's some physical activity and
the lack of does that those activities
outside is affecting him somehow he's
more nervous and difficult to manage
sometimes since the lockdown came in
adults have been allowed to go out for
essential reasons but children haven't
so Sunday was a big day for Marco the
new rules apply to children up to the
age of 13 only each adults is allowed to
go out with up to three children for one
hour and no further than one kilometer
from their home they still have to
observe distancing as this drone reminds
people meaning they can't beat up with
their friends and parks remain closed in
most places but specialists have
wandered the effect of the lockdown on
children's health and mental well-being
and this nine-year-old has certainly
missed just getting out the streets I
missed the streets and the park and
feeling the air on my face and I never
thought I would miss school but I really
do
Spain has the world's third highest
official coronavirus death toll but with
the number of daily deaths falling the
government's hoping to ease restrictions
further from next weekend's study are on
or Seattle is I would like to announce
that if the evolution of the pandemic
continues in a positive direction as it
is doing so far starting from May 2nd
people will be allowed to go out to
individual physical activity and walks
with the people with whom they live
however always in the conditions laid
down by the health authorities
[Music]
in the southern city of Seville the
annual fair isn't happening but that
hasn't stopped them celebrating with
people dancing traditional said be
honest on their balconies and generally
enjoying the chance to let their hair
down the City Council may hold the event
in September as part of a plan to
recover the tourism industry the right
now there's a cautious optimism in Spain
as people take stock of how many lives
the crisis has already taken nadine
barber al jazeera